[Applause]
six years of searching please
let this be it whoa focus
eyes forward took kelly marie tran is a
disney princess
did you ever think it would happen i'm
i think i'd have to be delusional to
think it would actually happen
um but yeah it's it's wild and it's
been an incredible journey i'm really
excited for people to meet rhett
the disney princess and the notion of
what it stands for has evolved
over the decades my first question for
you super quick is what was the one that
you grew up
loving the most and the second question
is how do you think the disney princess
has evolved to this point
it was nine when milan came out and uh
let me know when um
yeah so that that that movie meant a lot
to me and in terms of
how i think the idea of a disney
princess is changing
you know i think when um the original
like classic disney princess movie
started coming out there was a really
narrow
perception of what uh princesses looked
like and
spoke like and act like and dressed like
and now we're sort of
in this period where i think disney is
really making an effort to sort of
broaden what people think of when they
think of the idea of princess when they
think of the idea of hero
and it's really cool to be part of that
change to recognize that we are
um yeah opening up the doors for people
to realize
that anyone can be a princess or a hero
regardless
of what you look like or where you come
from um and any of those other sort of
specifics yeah uh favorite disney
princess um
well yeah i mean i think it's hard to
choose i definitely definitely love
mulan
obviously you know for those reasons i
really was obsessed with like
the the lion king and then like uh
aladdin and beauty and the beast
was like like i couldn't wait for that
and we actually just bonded over kelly
marie
uh kelly reminded me of this uh of uh
of this of the spin-off of what was it
called
and i just remember it was i watched it
beautiful enchanted christmas
christmas great janet christmas outfit
cinematic masterpiece obviously
yeah um were you guys a little bit
disappointed that there were no sort of
musical numbers in this one were you
guys ready to belt it out
i love musicals so obviously i would
have loved for it to be a musical but i
think what it turned out to be and
having it be an action movie is also
equally awesome
yes uh what did you think of okafina
when you first saw the design of sisu
in both forms uh you know it's funny i
didn't see the human form until
way later so i i actually just had just
saw sketches of uh
of of cece the dragon and i just
remember being like wow this is uh
really cool because i think that her
design and her influences and
and you know what what's gone into her
her makeup are uh
you know make her really unique and
she's unlike any other dragons
physically and also her personality
and uh the human form it looks like me i
think
like it has we have like a like similar
smile teeth
yeah yeah like them every time the mouth
i'm like talking to me
looking at me yeah so that's cool what
was it like for you kelly murray
seeing raya crazy um
yeah i just remember thinking that i had
never seen a princess that looks like
her before and
um it was really emotional i i think
it's it's also associated with
recognizing that you know
i get to be part of this and remembering
the legacy of
gosh how much disney movies sculpted my
childhood
um so yeah lots of emotions going on
here lots of feelings
i love that um i also want to commend
you both for making a movie during a
pandemic
never thought that would happen in
anyone's career but here we are doing an
entire
movie what was that like and were you
guys able to help each other through the
pandemic the last year as well
we didn't work um together that closely
obviously we did we did
half the movie was filmed in lockdown um
and uh
you know me and kelly and i haven't
really met
uh so much we haven't spent a lot of
time in person we've met at an event
but um i feel like i've really gotten to
know her over these these uh these press
interviews and and i really
i really love i really love her i love
you too man
we love each other yeah yeah i i was
sad that we um didn't get to really
interact that much but
obviously yeah just just a huge fan of
everything aquafina and
and now even more so just getting to
know her over this
crazy zoom press situation um so
hopefully once this is all over we will
hang out yeah hang out
i hear you on that one uh there were
beautiful combat and action sequences in
this movie
again you know with the singing question
but in this time i want to talk about
you kind of gutted that you weren't able
to do sort of your own stance or get
into the
the choreogra choreography of fighting
watching that movie
and just seeing and also i think what's
really cool about the martial arts is
the martial arts style that was used uh
to inspire everything
in the in this movie is specifically
from southeast asia one of our writers
qui win
is a martial arts expert and he was very
specific
about wanting to make sure that it
originated from this part of the world
which i
just think is incredible um but yeah
yeah i wish i could have done all that
fighting stuff that one part where i
think namari like
grabs my neck with her legs and like
flips me over i'm like yes so
yeah cool and we're talking about the
perfect pairings that we've seen
in the disney movies throughout the
decades as well and i wanted to know
what your perfect pairing
is in previous movies but also who the
best sidekick
is as well like we're talking olla from
frozen
the carpet or the genie or a poo from
aladdin
or scuttle from the little mermaid which
one's the best
sidekick i don't think scuttle is the
best
sky sidekick uh he he often gives me
some information
and um uh and he but he
you know when when he he's he's loyal so
that's good what what is i'm sorry what
is the i forgot his name i'm so sorry
the the bird uh from from the lion king
zazu zazu i think was was real like
really underestimated he was kind of
seen as kind of like a like a uptight
you know because he was really always
trying to
you know keep the schedule and whatnot
but i really think he he really wanted
to do
uh mufasa's you know do him right by
taking care of his boy
you know so i think he was a great he
was a great psychic yeah
yeah okay structure and order what about
you kelly marie
i really like simone and pumbaa as a duo
uh so funny and gosh some of their lines
i still remember
like that part where uh they're trying
to tempt the hyenas and timon's like
are you aching forward
yeah yeah he's a big pig you could be a
big pig too
[Laughter]
so good that wasn't good that was good
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
i would love to talk about namara i'm
nomari sorry because i think she's an
amazing
villain in the sense that usually a
disney villain
is sort of inherently evil they are bad
and they want bad
things but in this instance it seems
like her intentions are truly well
placed and she's not actually doing
the evil thing is that what you really
liked about namari as a character
yeah for sure the thing i i love about
namari is that she's
she's not a straight out villain um you
know she is the antagonist and she is
rya's nemesis but she and raya are also
two sides of the same coin
um they've just been raised very very
differently and been raised with very
different philosophies
and in terms of what they think the best
thing is to do
to keep their own to keep themselves
safe to keep their own
land safe um but yeah namari uh
she's she's she's badass she's a she's a
fierce warrior
um but she's also got you know a real
heart underneath that bravado
and what she and raya initially connect
with um as children
is their mutual love of dragons um and
that never leaves
um so despite the fact that the murray
grows up to
to be this um really quite um
tough aggressive character she's still
got that
that little girl that she was um is
underneath it all so
yeah all of that is really fun to play
uh we're in a pandemic
and uh productions definitely changed
big time during that
a lot of this movie if not the majority
of it
was made from home how was that for you
well it's it's definitely been
a a challenging um
time to to try and make a film um all i
will say is it's an
absolute credit to you know everyone
involved in this film you know not just
the cast but
primarily the the the directors the
the animators the um everyone kind of
you know on the crew i think there are
like 450
cars and crew that have made this film
respectfully from their own home
so it's a real kind of communal um
effort and i feel
so proud that that we've been able to to
to make this film during this very
difficult time
i am i kind of made a makeshift studio
downstairs
at home um you know putting stuff on the
walls to try and clad the sound and but
you know i've got really loud birds that
uh
chirp outside so i would have to try
saying my lines in between the kind of
bird cheats and yeah all of these kind
of challenges that you wouldn't have
expected um that kind of cropped up
um i want to talk about the evolution of
a disney princess i don't know about you
but as a kid i grew up on aladdin little
mermaid and i you know i
had this understanding of what a disney
princess was supposed to be
but with movies like raya and the last
dragon we are really seeing
the evolution of a disney princess going
in a whole new direction
what do you think about that sort of the
evolution here that we're seeing
you know i grew up watching those films
as well and i think what's so exciting
about
raya um and you know you you sort of
just
said with frozen as well but you have um
you know
female characters that very much have
agency
um and you know they're not waiting to
be rescued they are
they are out there in the world pursuing
what they want to pursue and you know
they're
they're not perfect they're not um you
know they're flawed
um but you know they're they're they're
fully rounded um
characters and it's important for
everyone watching not just the girls but
for boys and girls to kind of see that
um i love it um since you are a disney
fan and you know all about the
beautiful perfect pairings out there in
the side kick i mean we've seen the
likes of
mushu from milan we've got olaf from
frozen
genie from aladdin which one is your
favorite sidekick out there
oh my gosh
i'm a huge lion king fan so like uh
pumbaa yeah come on yeah he's he's gonna
be out there
we need you to defeat the evil with the
last of dragon magic
ah i'm gonna be real with you all right
i'm not like the
the best dragon the first thing i want
to talk about is this amazing
evolution of the disney princess that
we've seen throughout the decades having
grown up
with disney princesses you know i was
very much obsessed with it all
but it's so fascinating just to see sort
of like how you can flip the script
on a disney princess movie so my first
question for whoever wants to tackle
this one
is how do you think that raya has
evolved in the terms of like the way the
disney princess has been seen
um i came from off of moana and on to uh
ryan the last dragon and and i think
this evolution has been ongoing
i think the the the disney princess has
always been an aspirational character
and we look at we look at her as the
leader
on raya we literally spent some time
thinking about does she need to be a
princess just because she's a hero
and we landed on yes because we liked
her having that sense of responsibility
as a leader
and to her people and i think the the
princess is just like everything else
sort of reflects who we are these are
very personal films
and we all bring our sense of who we are
and for me
i come from israel from like a line of
strong women
my friends are strong women um the
friendships between women we get to
explore all of that in this movie
so um to me it's sort of a natural
evolution because we were there
to have that conversation and the whole
team was was was really into it
and uh i would just add selfishly as so
as you know someone who grew up in
southeast asia
and and like you you know having and
enjoying and loving all the disney
princesses
i love that we have a new disney
princess
that i can look at and that my daughter
can look at and see herself reflected in
in her face it's tremendous and i think
the the bigger
you know message whether you're a little
girl or a little boy in like southeast
asia or anywhere in the world that no
matter what you look like or where you
come from
that your face and your story is so much
worth celebrating
talking about southeast asia how was it
building a law around sort of
encompassing
all of that domain well we uh
we knew we wanted to tell a story that
is about you know we looked around us
and we're looking at
how divided we all are and how we use
our differences against each
other rather than to come together and
do something greater than you know than
the sum of our parts and
um we went on our first research trip to
southeast asia and one of the things
that struck us everywhere we went
talking about a vast region 11 countries
multiple cultures and traditions
and religions and everywhere we went
there was a sense of community and of
people coming together for something
greater than themselves and so and we
already knew that we wanted to work with
the asian dragon we're so drawn to the
dragon of
of water and and harmony and life and so
we came back and said that's it that's
the inspiration is going to be from
southeast asia
and so we started working with experts
with architects and and
um anthropologists and and textile
masters
to find one of the unifying elements and
how can we apply those into the world of
commander which is a completely
fictional world so
it was this constant balance but i'd say
that a big
important part of really doing the work
was
to have key members of our of our team
being southeast asian including adele
and and queer co-writer and
and fauna head of story and many others
so that that
kind of lived experience permeates the
film
and i loved like when you touched upon
these things that are so indicative of
the culture
like the representation of food and how
that is celebrated and how amazing that
looked and like
coming from like a ghibli fan it was so
amazing just
you know really honoring the the the
food in that and so that was great um
and i also love you know
exploring all the different locations
and like the fish the fishing boats and
the transport
what was something that was super
important to bring for you adele
oh it's so funny well you've already
touched on one of those aspects like the
food
so i think it was two things first you
know um
uh the respect the respect and the love
for the inspiration you know there were
all these little details things that you
know may not jump out to you on the
screen
but you know how uh children are with
their parents how uh you know each peop
each person shows each other respect the
sign of the respect that we show
inspired by you know many hand gestures
that the of the different uh countries
in southeast asia
um and two the food
so it starts from a place of like just
visceral joy if you know anyone from
southeast asia you know how obsessed we
are with our food
um and so you know it would be in the
script it would be you know with the
southeast asian people in
our story department and visual
development and animators
you will get so excited by it and just
lovingly render it
because you know in the region it's how
people communicate love
it's how we bring people together and
there was also
you know um a larger message to it which
is um just the country i come from
malaysia there's so many races religions
like histories
it's easy to see these things as
differences that divide us you know and
should and make us view each other as
the enemy
but truly when you look at what's
wonderful about our region and our
country the arts and our street food the
best street food in the world
it's because of these different
influences that all you know help us
make something transcendent
and so that's why you'll see you know
food being used as a metaphor throughout
you know throughout the movie
yeah i was salivating it was amazing um
i also have to commend
the fact that this movie was made during
a pandemic i mean we never thought that
we'd have to
work from home in this kind of capacity
what were some of the things you learned
about sort of getting through a pandemic
and still being able to make a movie
well first of all that it can be done
because if you would have asked me a
year ago before
just before we went into lockdown i
would have said no absolutely not we
cannot do this
and then when we went home and we
thought we were going home for three
weeks and we already
you know wondered what it would do to
our schedule and it's been a year here
we're still in our first lockdown and um
the technological issues yeah they were
there but we had an amazing technology
team and they solved things
really quickly we were up and running
and even dealing with everyone's
bandwidth everyone of course had to deal
with the kids going to school there in
the back and
their own their own questions but i
think for us the biggest
hurdle was cultural we like to be in the
room together build on each other's
ideas throw out ideas go get food talk
about it
and to learn how to do that without the
happenstance of running into each other
and having a coffee together
and in this kind of zoom environment it
took us time
but also we realized you can only do it
for so long so we structured and
disciplined our days
so much more that a we all ended up
having you know dinner with our families
which we don't usually do
during production but more importantly
we realized that we had to trust each
other more because we had to delegate
more
and so there you were the the movie
living through the
making of the movie during the pandemic
and um
the crew pulled through i i'm super
proud of the crew of this movie
we've been talking about the disney
sidekicks that we've seen throughout all
the different movies as well
we've got two new ones here i guess with
sisu who's kind of like reminding me of
aladdin and then also tuk tuk who's like
sort of i'm i mean i'm
heavily inspired with like the aladdin
side of things here but what would be
your ideal sidekick out of all the
disney movies whether it's olaf from
frozen
out of all of them who would you choose
oh
hands down like you know i and it's
funny you mentioned sisu and that like
for us sisu is more of a you know is
more of a fully fledged
character that she's the best friend of
raya but in terms of having the
you know your buddy who's always with
you through thick and thin who never
judges who that in you know
and you never get feel lonely because
he's always there
because you can also ride him like out
here exactly because then he will still
go 60 miles an hour and get you to where
you need to go like an off-road vehicle
so
yeah twofer you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
super excited about this one um mainly
because we are
exploring a whole new area when it comes
to
disney princesses and unity and all
these amazing themes but i want to talk
about the evolution of the disney
princess
because she has been changing over the
decades and raya is like
so formidable and i wanted to hear from
you how did you land on
not only this story but raya as a disney
princess
yeah yeah we're very proud of of this
character and
and obviously it was a combination of so
many things but um
you know first and foremost i think we
we tended to
we i mean obviously we were aware that
she was a princess she's the daughter of
the chief but
but i think you know if asked i think
raya would identify more
as a warrior you know and and
specifically a guardian of the dragon
gem you know that's that was what she
spent her entire life
childhood trying to to be and and
becomes in the film and then she becomes
a guardian of an actual dragon as well
so
um i i think we're we love that there's
that duality to raya that she
obviously can be in the pantheon of
disney princesses but also
you know as a formidable warrior
formidable enough that she could be an
avenger in our opinion
so um and that was the product of a lot
of different things you know
i think you know our desire to craft a
character that was um
i mean obviously had the physicality
that was necessary for an action
adventure film but
but also a sense of humor and a wit
about her
i think we love that she's confident and
at times overconfident
has a swagger you know um but also can
be vulnerable
and kind of pour her heart out at times
and so i think we're
most uh in love with the fact that it
that she's a nuanced complex character
and then of course you add kelly marie
into the mix and it becomes a whole
another ball game
but ultimately i think we're just very
proud of of this character ryan
well that was actually my next question
what was it about kelly marie tran
um that you decided she was just perfect
for the role i
i think a lot of it comes from what don
just spoke about just the
the nuances that we wanted raya to have
as a character
she has some of the most heart-wrenching
scenes that we've
ever seen but she also has some of the
lighter funnier moments we've ever seen
and she needs to be
able to play next to aquafina who is
really fast on her feet
and is really funny and really sharp and
kelly did that
not only that but she has a really
strong cultural connection to the world
of our movie
and it meant a lot for her to represent
the first uh southeast asian
disney princess disney heroine um
so that was sort of like like on like
the surface level but what was most
incredible about having kelly on is that
she really connected to the movie to the
ideas of the movie to
thematic elements and she became
essentially an ambassador for
ryan the last dragon she's been really
going out there and
showing off the pride that she feels uh
to be connected to this movie the pride
that she feels in our team animation
she was so involved with her crew in
every step of the way
she would uh interview them about what
they're doing and really went the extra
mile
to uh really sort of like become a part
of this community that was putting the
movie together
and actors you know don't normally do
that sometimes because of time sometimes
because of interest but kelly really
really just sort of like became a part
of the family
and we honestly could not be more proud
to have her
uh leading this this incredible
uh package uh we've seen so many
different types of dragons over the
years as well
um the lore of the dragon in itself is
amazing
how did you settle on the look for these
dragons
uh well the dragon on on this one you
know usually when you're watching a big
hollywood film most of the dragons are
western dragons dragons that you know
breathe fire
and often are like monsters that need to
be bankers to get to some sort of
treasure
uh the you know since there's a movie
that was highlighting southeast asian
cultures
the the dragon that we wanted to
spotlight was one that was from the
region
uh which was based on the naga uh which
is kind of the opposite where the
western dragon's a dragon of
intimidation
uh you know eastern dragon or southeast
asian dragon one of inspiration
it's seen as almost a deity one that's
full of hope and life and harmony
and so to have a dragon that was so
kind of full of life and and was here to
inspire people
and then you you smash that up against
like a comedic genius like aquafina
that's cruel
that those two things combined together
is what really defined what
this dragon needed to look like what it
needed to be like and how we were going
to interact with it because we didn't
want it to be like a beast it had to be
a full character
that you would fall in love with but
also treat as a peer
on and you made them more pretty pastels
for us so thank you
i was trying to think about the genre of
this film because
i was watching it and i'm like is this a
heist film
there are moments i mean the most sure
uh little noi and the hungies break into
uh
namari's uh uh room is kind of a heist
and we we fully embrace it we were like
let's go osha's 11
on this yeah with a baby and some
ocean 11 months
[Laughter]
hey i also want to talk about the fact
that this is um
the first sort of disney animated film
in a while where we haven't had a
singing ensemble
and like you know big big big powerful
tunes behind it what was the decision
behind that one
um well i think early on you know that
this movie's always going was
always going to be a big epic uh
action-adventure fantasy film
and um to to kind of throw musical
numbers or songs into the mix i think it
just would have imploded
you know by and um so
uh but i will say music was hugely
important
in terms of our score from james newton
howard um
on on in every level by every metric i
mean this is an
incredible score uh it's traditional on
one hand
fully modern on another uh and
incorporates so many
uh uh instrumentations from uh
the regions of southeast asia so it's
really kind of a miracle score and
and even though you know it's not a
musical you know a lot of the scenes
almost feel
musical in terms of because they'll be
you know not a lot of dialogue in some
of the fight scenes and so
they're they almost become almost like
songs in a way without
people singing them you know i will say
that at some point
in in the process of development uh we
were considering giving sisu
uh like a spoken word uh element
to her that she wasn't gonna quite break
break into into poetry but
there was an intro that we were gonna
ask aquafina to do a little bit of
rhyming and then we
quickly realized that was not the right
thing to do
so we uh we kept it as a as a straight
drama
we've been talking about the perfect
pairs that have existed in disney movies
especially with the sidekick so i want
to ask all of you
out of all the sidekicks that we've seen
throughout the decades in movies i'm
talking olaf
mushi i'm talking um you know a poo
scuttle who's your favorite sidekick to
date huh
you know i the first thing that came to
my mind and uh it's an oldie but a
goodie but um
is the carpet from aladdin i love
i love that i love non-verbal characters
uh because we just it just that's such
animation
heaven and our animators get to do so
much great work and so
uh that carpet was uh uh totally amazing
to me and and still holds up to this day
yeah i'm gonna stick into aladdin but i
want to move over to the genie
because i just love like those iconic
you know when the the perfect character
meets the perfect actor
uh much like sisu to aquafina it's just
a memorable character that will
be stuck in our imaginations forever so
so for
so the genie is definitely my top my
favorite
disney psychic pair is
uh don hall and i because we
are magical and charming beyond
belief it may
feel impossible but sometimes
you just have to take the first step
[Music]
i just shave change dragons can do that
look how close my butt is to my head